– Schneller!
– Warte!
– Oh nein. Nico!
– Du kannst es.
– Nein, kann ich nicht.
Oh Gott!
– Danke.
– Das war gut. Du bist …
– ... ein Naturtalent!
– Ja.
Letzte Woche konntest du noch
gar nicht Fahrrad fahren.
Und das war richtig gut. Toll!
– Danke …
Das macht Spaß!
– Selma, warum …
warum wollen deine Eltern nicht,
dass wir uns sehen?
– Was?
Nein, das …
Sie wollen nicht, dass ich mich
alleine mit Männern treffe.
– Du bist erwachsen. Du kannst
machen, was du willst!
– Bei uns kann ich als Frau nicht
einfach so jemanden treffen.
Das geht nicht.
– Als meine Eltern jung waren, durften sie
sich auch nicht sehen, aber heute ...
– Bei uns ist das heute auch noch so.
Meine Eltern …
– Ich komme mit meinen Eltern
auch nicht zurecht.
– Wieso auch?
Ich liebe meine Eltern.
– Aber …?
– In Syrien hat der Mann bis heute
in einigen traditionellen Familien
andere Pflichten als die Frau.
Die Frau hat zum Beispiel
Aufgaben im Haushalt,
der Mann geht arbeiten.
Meine Familie erwartet von mir,
dass ich unsere Tradition respektiere.
– Na ja.
Hast du dieses Mal die Wahrheit gesagt?
Wissen deine Eltern, wo du bist?
– Los, noch mal!